Avengers endgame has made more money
than any movie ever but it hasn't sold
the most tickets in fact it isn't even
in the top 15 from romantic epics to
horror hits here's a look at all the
blockbusters from years past whose crowd
sizes would have been pressed even Panos
the first film on our list is Ben Hur no
we're not talking about the infamous
2016 bomb that lost paramount a
mind-numbing 120 million dollars younger
filmmakers may not have known it but
that recent Ben Hur was based on a 1959
multi-million dollar epic that was one
of the biggest hits of all time the film
starred Charlton Heston one of
Hollywood's most popular and successful
actors still with an astronomical budget
of fifteen million dollars Ben Hur was a
massive gamble by MGM which was hoping
that the movie could pull it out of
impending bankruptcy if Ben Hur was
their last hope it answered all of their
prayers fortunately for the studio The
Epoch made seventy four million dollars
domestically which is eight hundred and
eighty three million dollars in today's
money all told the blockbuster saved MGM
from bankruptcy and became acknowledged
as a classic that's still being talked
about today in 1977 the original Star
Wars also known as a new poked more than
conquered the box office it forever
changed the movie landscape and pop
culture in general you know sometimes I
amaze even myself naturally its first
sequel was highly anticipated so much so
that 1980s The Empire Strikes Back
opened to nearly five million dollars in
just 126 theaters during its initial
limited run and ten million dollars once
it expanded to 823 theaters even today
with our multiplex culture those numbers
would be impressive but when adjusted
for inflation they would be
earth-shattering all told empires
initial run earned more than 209 million
dollars but it wasn't finished the film
was re-released several more times in
today's numbers its total domestic gross
stands at eight hundred and eighty four
million dollars feeding out Avengers
endgame by 30 million dollars Kiska camp
we lost everyone loves dogs Disney and
cartoon so it's no surprise that 1961's
101 Dalmatians which combines all three
was a huge moneymaker the film is a
classic from the tail end of Disney's
Gold
with a quirky story some catchy tunes
and an iconic villain and Cruella De Vil
it was a big hit in its initial run but
the film made most of it's money in
subsequent re-releases in fact the 1991
re-release celebrating the movie's 30th
anniversary made 60 million dollars
clearly the Spotted pups had more
staying power than its initial release
would have suggested all tolled 101
Dalmatians has made a hundred and forty
four million dollars domestically or
just over nine hundred million dollars
when adjusted for inflation and we know
we're dropping a lot of numbers on you
but when it comes to this classic movie
there's only one number that really
matters the force awakens is the seventh
film in the extremely popular Star Wars
franchise and the first sequel to the
original series in more than 30 years
bringing Harrison Ford Carrie Fisher and
Mark Hamill back to the roles that made
them famous even for a Star Wars movie
expectations were extremely high people
are coming on us the galaxy has come
behind us the force awakens was the
first Star Wars film to open during the
holiday season and it turned out to be a
stroke of genius while it had a
record-breaking first weekend if you
look closely at the numbers the movies
true accomplishment came in the months
that followed after opening like a
summer blockbuster it played like a
holiday hit continuing to earn millions
week after week by the end of its
explosive run the force awakens had
earned nine hundred and thirty six
million dollars domestically adjusted
for inflation that's 974 million dollars
today
Disney has enjoyed a remarkable run a
box office success in the 21st century
but its all-time biggest ticket seller
didn't come from Marvel Lucasfilm or
Pixar no their biggest hit comes from
the Golden Age of animation in fact it's
their oldest movie the animated classic
Snow White's in the seventh warps
Hollywood thought Walt Disney was nuts
when he set out to release a
feature-length animated film less than a
decade after Mickey Mouse debuted in
Steamboat Willie cartoons were strictly
the domain of shorts that played before
the main feature Disney changed all that
and the movie business too was Snow
White
the animated classic earned impressive
numbers during its initial release in
nineteen
37 becoming the top grossing film that
year Snow White was re-released eight
times culminating in a total domestic
gross of more than 184 million dollars
which would add up to 982 million
dollars today from an animated
family-friendly classic to a satanic
horror film in which an innocent young
girl turns into a head spinning bile
spewing demonic little monster well at
least you can say American moviegoers
have eclectic tastes one of the most
influential horror films ever The
Exorcist is still shocking and
terrifying today but in 1973 a shock
factor was near scandalous and all that
scandal helped the exorcist scare up a
ton of cash combining its initial run
and a later re-release the exorcist has
now made more than two hundred and
thirty million dollars domestically
which rises up to nine hundred and
ninety-six million dollars when adjusted
for inflation making it the all-time top
ticket seller among r-rated movies The
Exorcist isn't the highest-grossing
however the r-rated film with that honor
ironically enough is the Passion of the
Christ dr. Zhivago is the very
definition of an epic historical romance
so genre that doesn't get a lot of love
from movie studios anymore
why is that well for one they're
incredibly expensive they're also very
risky most problematic you can't turn
them into a franchise that said when
they hit they hit big dr. Zhivago
definitely qualifies it features
stunning visuals captivating melodrama
and beautiful leads playing lovers who's
doomed romance is torn asunder by the
winds of history based on Russian
novelist Boris Pasternak's book and
directed by the king of the epic David
Lean dr. Zhivago stars Omar Sharif and
Julie Christie as people in love with
each other but married to others during
the Russian Revolution improved the
significantly bigger hit than leans
other epochs earning 111 million dollars
or an adjusted gross of over 1 billion
dollars incredibly it wasn't even the
biggest hit of 1965 but more on that
later for now it's safe to say that
Doctor Zhivago was the Titanic of its
time full of romance and tragedy just
without any unfortunate catchphrases
when jaws popped up in 1975 it
practically invented the summer movie
season breaking box-office records and
frightening people away from beaches
lakes ponds and even a few pools based
on Peter Benchley's novel of the same
name the problem plagued production
nearly ended relative newcomer Steven
Spielberg's career but ultimately all
the technical snafus forced the young
director to get inventive by creating a
theater of the mind he made movie
history delivering suspenseful moments
that were far more effective because he
was forced to keep his tooth the
antagonist off screen for much of the
film Spielberg's improvisation worked
jaws opened on June 20th 1975 and
quickly blew up to an inflation-adjusted
gross of 1.15 three billion dollars by
any measure calling that a boatload of
cash would be an understatement you're
gonna need a bigger motion director
Cecil B DeMille his name is practically
synonymous with epic as his lavish
productions achieved a scope and
grandeur that will simply never be
matched by the CGI pumping up today's
blockbusters he was also a risk-taker
and the 10 commandments is proof who
else but DeMille would remake one of the
biggest movies of all time especially
when he was the one who directed the
original version in 1923 more than 30
years later the film industry was facing
stiff competition from TV and movies had
to get bigger to compete and thanks to
DeMille the Ten Commandments is as big
as it gets it opened on October 5th 1956
and earned 85 million dollars by the end
of its run easily becoming the
highest-grossing film of the year and
one of the most enduring biblical
portraits in the history of cinema when
you think of Moses on film you think of
dimille's the Ten Commandments well you
might also think of this if you were
alive in the late 1990s you'll always
remember Titanic crossing a
record-breaking 200 million dollars to
produce the film was viewed by many as a
career sinking folly for director James
Cameron and those predictions seem to be
confirmed when it opened to an
unimpressive 28 million dollars on
December 19 1997 but then something
strange happened Titanic didn't sink
well the movie didn't the next weekend
the film made 24% more than the weekend
before and it just kept on selling
tickets as millions of people would
tackle the 194 minute runtime to see it
again and again by the time it was all
said and done Titanic made what was then
an unpatentable six hundred million
dollars domestically the film was later
re-released in 3d and a twentieth
anniversary reissue followed in 2017
while Titanic's box office ship has
sailed its total haul now stands at six
hundred and fifty nine million dollars
or 1.2 to 1 billion dollars when
adjusted for inflation film buffs will
argue over Steven Spielberg's defining
masterpiece for decades to come
what is an up for debate is his biggest
hit ET the extra-terrestrial in a career
full of box-office glory including one
record-breaking mega hit after another
the fact that et is Spielberg's biggest
blockbuster says a lot it opened to 11
million dollars On June 11 1982 and much
like Titanic kept making money it holds
the record for the most non consecutive
weekends at number one and fluctuated
between first and second positions on
the box office charts for five solid
months by the end of its first
theatrical run ET had earned three
hundred and fifty nine million dollars
passing star wars as the
highest-grossing film ever ET earned
another seventy million dollars in
re-release it's bringing its total to
four hundred and thirty-five million
dollars or one point two seven eight
billion dollars adjusted for inflation
which is something you definitely want
to phone home about the 1960s are
remembered as an era of rebellion
experimentation and free love but when
it came to movies the biggest hits were
the ones you could watch with your
parents and that was never more true
than in 1965 Doctor Zhivago was enormous
ly successful with its mix of history
and romance but it was beat out by The
Sound of Music the most successful movie
musical of all time the film is based on
Rodgers and Hammerstein's classic 1959
play and while it took six years to go
from Broadway to the big screen the
movies producers were not disappointed
The Sound of Music was a blockbuster
opening wide on March 2nd 1965 and
ultimately earning approximately a
hundred and fifty
million dollars do all of its releases
for a total of one point two eight three
billion dollars in today's door Amy Star
Wars is arguably the most popular
franchise ever it's second only to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in total box
office numbers as mentioned previously
the phenomenon began in 1977 with Star
Wars a new hope initially only a handful
of theaters ordered the movie in fact it
opened in only 43 venues on the same
weekend as a surefire summer hit Smokey
and the Bandit box was convinced that
their sci-fi swashbuckler would be
crushed by the competition history had
other ideas
Star Wars earned 1.5 million dollars in
its opening weekend Fox broadened its
release to meet demand which kept
growing and growing during its first 18
month run the film stayed on target to
make a mind-boggling 307 million dollars
which grew with five re-releases over
the course of 20 years
all told Star Wars earned four hundred
and sixty million dollars and after we
adjust that for inflation it equals one
point six zero four billion dollars
money is all that you love and that's
what you'll receive there can only be
one winner and it's hard to fathom that
any movie will ever sell more tickets
than Gone with the Wind based on
Margaret Mitchell's best-selling novel
of the same name with a pretty
substantial budget of 3.9 million
dollars and starring the king of
Hollywood himself Clark Gable everybody
knew Gone with the Wind was going to be
a hit it was just a matter of how big
MGM got its answer when 300,000 people
arrived for the premiere in Atlanta on
December 15 1939 its initial run earned
mammoth numbers inspiring multiple
re-releases through several decades all
told the movie has earned 200 million
dollars that's more than most releases
today but it's truly mind-boggling
considering its adjusted gross would be
1.8 to 2 billion dollars which should be
extremely impressive to anyone frankly
yeah I don't give a damn check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite blockbuster films are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]